valérie planté denis coderre son
candidat à la mairie de montréal et
cette semaine ils ont participé à un
débat politique
ils ont fait valoir leurs arguments et
on en ne vérifie quelles que soient
[Musique]
on commence avec les autobus ce que j'ai
dit c'est qu'il aurait 300 autobus
hybrides de plus sur les routes on peut
produire et je vais vous donner 300
autobus 6 20 20 ou si vous allez les
mecs
vérification faite denis coderre a
raison s'il fallait augmenter la flotte
de 300 autobus et 2020 soit qu'il n'y
aurait pas de place même dans les
installations qu'on construit en ce
moment où qu'il faudra puis sur
l'accélérateur pour mettre en branle un
nouveau projet de garage autre sujet de
ce débat le big band
parce que si montréal peut avoir à
nouveau une équipe et devrait avoir un
nouveau stade au centre-ville
mais est-ce que ça aura un impact sur
les finances des monts réel sachant très
bien sûr les exemples des visites que ça
ne fait même pas augmenter les taxes
dans d'autres villes qui ont utilisé
l'argent des contribuables
valérie planté juste dans l'exemple
qu'elle donne au moins deux villes las
vegas aux états unis et regina au canada
ont haussé les taxes pour financer des
stades
denis coderre crois qu'il est trop tôt
pour savoir combien d'argent plus de
l'extrait demandé pour un stade à
montréal payer une étude de 2013 qui
estimait qu'il fallait au moins 335
millions de dollars on sait que valérie
plante peut implanter une nouvelle ligne
de métro la rose et denis coderre a
lancé un chiffre sur les coûts la ligne
rose le 5 août le minimum 6 millions de
dollars denis coderre 10 milliards
projet montréal 6 milliards le parti de
valéry plantes en fête s'est basé sur
les données de 20 projets qui ont été
réalisés aux états unis au canada et en
europe mais prudence avec les chiffres
parce que vous savez à montréal on
étudie sérieusement l'idée de prolonger
une autre ligne de métro la ligne bleue
depuis le début des années 2000
et encore aujourd'hui a pas de chiffres
officiels on ne sait pas combien ça va
coûter
si vous voulez quand on vérifie quelques
jours écrit